hart aber herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video hat wahrscheinlich gerade
den titelgewinn und denkt euch so hat
uns angelogen real in einer gewissen
form muss ich euch in diesem video etwas
beichten
deswegen wäre es mir wirklich wichtig
wenn ihr bis zum ende dran bleibt ich
versuche das auch so kurz wie möglich zu
halten
danke schön ich könnte schwören dass die
meisten leute die sich dieses video
jetzt gerade anschauen das
wahrscheinlich ähnlich wissen nicht
mitbekommen haben und sich darf auch gar
nicht interessieren ist es auch gerade
kein aktuelles thema es hat nichts mit
irgendwelchen anderen youtuber zu tun
ist es nur was was ich euch vorher
gesagt habe was aber nicht ganz gestimmt
hat aber ich erzähle jetzt mal so ein
bisschen um damit die gesamtsituation
versteht ich bin keine youtuber der
unglaublich viel aus seinem privatleben
preisgibt also ihr habt von mir noch nie
durch room to irgendwie aus meiner
kompletten wohnung gesehen ich habe euch
noch nie gesagt ja schaut mal irgendwie
das ist meine familie dass sie sind
kindheits fotos von mir das hier ist
dies oder das ist mir alles an theken zu
privat viele leute haben auch ihren
richtigen namen überall publish und
vielen leuten weil dann auch die
handy-nummer mit ihren anrufen kann und
so was alles mögliche das ist über mich
weiß man im vergleich zu anderen youtube
an recht wenig will ich mal grob
behaupten ihr wisst nicht ob ich
beispielsweise jetzt schon fünf sechs
monate in der beziehung wenn ihr wisst
nicht okay ist wie alt ich bin und wie
ich heiße und so was alles über ihr
bisher unter anderem auch nicht genau wo
ich wohne im sommer 2004 ist dann habe
ich mein abi gemacht wo ich halt
selbstverständlich bei meinen eltern
gewohnt habe in einem vorort von
bielefeld und dann wollte ich halt
unbedingt direkt studieren weil viele
leute sagen okay nachdem habe ich will
erst mal reisen bin ich überhaupt kein
fan von kann ich nachvollziehen
natürlich sagen leute direkt auch ich
will die welt sehen aber ich würde es
eher so machen dass ich irgendwas
studieren was in der hand habe und dann
bin ich 21 bin reise beim 1
das ist in so vielen ländern einfach so
wie bei uns das 18 jahre alt sein also
ich finde unter 21 braucht man
eigentlich nicht so richtig rumreisen
sorry das ist nur meine meinung also
wenn ihr da anderer meinung seid
respektiere ich das vollkommen japanern
auf jeden fall dieser 18 jährige luca de
unbedingt studieren wollte hat darauf
eine tolle hochschule gefunden die wahl
in hamburg und habe ich auch unbedingt
hin habt ihr auf der welt besucht habe
schon nach wohnungen gekauft und so
weiter und so fort dann habe ich schon
in videos gesagt ja auch freunde von
ganzen studierenden wird ultra coole
freu mich schon voll drauf ich kann mich
meine videos erinnert ich kann jetzt
auch keine ausschnitte einblenden weil
ich nicht genau dem wort laut gesagt hab
aber ich habe damals einen videos gesagt
ein paar sekunden später andere menschen
können noch brauchen ohne dabei übelste
lautstärke von sich zu geben lieber
nachbar aber hey ich hab dich mein paket
nicht für mich an genau ich habe den ich
liebte es auf jeden fall direkt
verbreitet dass ich irgendwie nach
hamburg ziehen will dass ich dort nie
gefunden habe das total cool wird weil
ich so weit komme von zu hause und sogar
und da bin ich dann auf jeden fall
umgezogen und habe dann immer noch so
videos gedacht so wenn leute mich
gefragt hey du wohnst du dich mal aufs
ganze hamburg und auch als ich dann
beispielsweise beim fifa event war
sparen will dass er sich damals bei
instagram hochgeladen das war auch in
hamburg habe ich halt immer so gesagt ja
hier in hamburg bei mir direkt nebenan
war halt dieses event und das war alles
gelogen
ich wohne nicht in hamburg und hat noch
nie in hamburg gelebt dass die türme
warum liebe den scherben auf dem boden
man ich habe auf jeden fall in ultra
vielen videos immer gesagt
beziehungsweise die frage nach meinem
wohnort dementsprechend beantwortet ja
ich wurde in hamburg ich bin sehr
glücklich da blabla aber irgendwann habe
ich das ganze auch nur noch unter den
teppich gekehrt habe gar nichts mehr
wenn mein wohnort gesagt nur noch dass
meine familie halt in bielefeld wurden
und das habe ich halt gemacht weil ich
nicht weiter diese lüge erzählen wollte
dass ich in hamburg lebe weil wir zeigen
sich wahrscheinlich für viele jahre was
hat ihr haus angelegt oder links am
schluss aber ihr müsst mal meine
situation so ein bisschen verstehen und
das versuche ich euch ein bisschen
beizubringen gerade natürlich bin ich
jetzt keine wiebels der welt da und ich
will mich auch überhaupt nicht als da
ansehen weil für mich ist ein star eine
person die von jeder anderen person
erkannt werden könnte also von leuten
die alle sind von leuten die jungen sind
solche leute wie angela merkel sind für
mich in einer gewissen form star dass
sie irgendwie kennt sein 15 jähriger
oder seine 70-jährige bei uns youtuber
ist es so wir sind nur bei der community
quasi bekannt dass also nur bei den
leuten bekannt die auf der plattform
youtube unterwegs sind
es steht ihr was ich meine aber um aufs
thema zurückzukommen ich damals bei
meiner familie gewesen irgendwie 2013
ende 2013 anfang 2014 und da stand auf
einmal leute vor der tür und hamme
bionade vorbeigebracht und meinen so
janssen einen video gesagt max
bionahrung wieder mal gesehen wie du
hier ist das in verden gedacht du wohnst
ihr blabla an sich ultra coole aktionen
danke für die bionade auf der anderen
seite sieht sowas als komplett
privatsphäre schädigen luca du bist so
undankbar sein
zuschauer von dir hier behandelt darüber
vernünftig wie gesagt ich bin da eine
sehr zurückhaltende person was wo mein
privatleben angeht und als ich das
mitbekommen habe habe ich mir gedacht
und zu dem zeitpunkt war es nämlich
gerade so dass ich zu den plan gefasst
hatte nach dem abi nach hamburg zu gehen
das ist mir dann auf jeden fall nach
meinem abi wieder bewusst geworden und
daher war es dann halt so dass ich
gesagt habe okay ich gehe doch nicht
nach hamburg sondern es hier nach köln
sage aber weiterhin dass ich nach
hamburg ziehen und tue so als wäre ich
dann nach hamburg gezogen und habe ich
gesagt du ja ob man hier dass beide
wohnung in hamburg hier sind neue
hintergrund war das war alles schon in
köln dadurch an eine wohnung in der
innenstadt gekommen habe dann auch noch
nie in köln gefunden habe aber trotzdem
weiterhin videos gesagt dass ich in
hamburg lebe und das haben wir sehr
viele leute geglaubt und irgendwann ist
es einfach selber schwer gefallen leuten
zu antworten ich wohne in hamburg und
immer diese lüge sag ich mal
aufrechtzuerhalten ich weiß das hört
sich jetzt total flehend und und
bescheuert wahrscheinlich an aber bitte
sieht diese lüge nicht als lüge an
sondern als art so sicherheit
beziehungsweise verteidigung von von mir
also es ist halt wirklich so ich hab
schon so oft erlebt dass ich irgendwie
das vermeide hause zu vertrauen von fans
verfolgt wohl ich will mich nicht
beschweren sich viele kommt also immer
freundlich wie es ist wenn man irgendwie
von drei verschiedenen gruppen verfolgt
wird und zwar um sein eigenes gebiet
hier rumlaufen muss und irgendwie
abschütteln muss um dann taxi zu nehmen
und noch eine extra runde zu fahren um
dann zu seinem wohnort
das ist nicht schön baby hatte früher
amazon video dazu gemacht wo sehr viele
fans vom youtube aufstand da die adresse
rausbekommen und ich sage euch es nicht
schlimmer als leute vor sich zu haben
die die privatsphäre nicht schätzen ich
hoffe ich kann das weniger gut
rüberbringen dass er nicht so sauer auf
mich sein weil die sache ist einfach ich
habe das mit hamburg die ganze zeit bei
kompletter form ist schief sehe ich
gerade wachsen
beck ich hab das auf jeden fall immer
dauerhaft mitbekommen wie mehr youtuber
gesagt haben leute schild camp nicht vor
hotels wenn wir da sind kommt uns nicht
zu nahe verfolgt und bis zu unserem
wohnort unsere freunde wir sind auch nur
ganz normale menschen ich habe jetzt
nicht wie ich aus dem jeweiligen risikos
vor der tür stehen die aufpasst dass
keine fans an mich rankommen oder so ich
bin wirklich auch ein ganz normaler
menschen dass ich irgendwie so ein paar
leute im internet mit mit videos gegen
die unterhalte und deswegen wollte ich
früher einfach nicht sagen die leute
nach hamburg sondern nicht sie nach köln
sondern dann hab ich gesagt ja ich wohne
in hamburg ohne aber in köln aber ich
glaube ihr wisst was ich meine ich will
darüber nicht so lange reden fakt es
einfach irgendwann habe ich dann für
mich selbst beschlossen ich sage gar
nichts mehr weil meinen wohnort und sagt
das ist privat aber jetzt möchte ich
einfach sagen okay ich habe gesagt ich
wohne in hamburg aber als freund ich
habe noch nie in meinem leben in hamburg
gewohnt das war alles nur eine lüge ich
hoffe aber ihr könnt es irgendwie
nachvollziehen und hättet jetzt sich rum
und gebt daumen runter ihr müsst einfach
mal so ein bisschen versuchen euch dann
meine lage rhein zu versetzen also ich
habe das wirklich mit hamburg nicht
gesagt und irgendwie zu verarschen oder
um jetzt dieses video machen zu können
und ist zu nennen ich habe euch
angelogen eigentlich wollte ich
überhaupt nicht sagen
irgendwie kann ich ihnen nicht mehr so
richtig damit leben dass so das wird
sich viel zu krass an ich sehe einfach
dauerhaft menschen die schreiben
luca wo wohnst und andere menschen die
antwort der wirtin hamburger sandra und
seiner story by step team erfolg dass er
nach köln fährt und alle so hey was ist
denn jetzt los hier ich wohl in köln
machte aber nichts mit anderen youtube
also ich bin ich wegen youtube nach köln
gezogen sondern nur weil ich die uni
hier schön fahren und ich hoffe damit
konnte ich euch jetzt diesen titel so
ein bisschen ex planen also dass ich
euch angelogen habe
das war eine sehr lange lüge die ging
jetzt irgendwie war 12 jahre tot also
ich hoffe dass sie mich trotzdem nie mit
falls sie mich gemacht habt oder so aber
ich werde jetzt auch das video meine
damen und herren wenn es irgendwie
verstehen könnten vielleicht eine
bewertung da und auf jeden fall mal 1
kommentar was ihr von so was halt das
war wirklich nur sondern ja nur um mich
selbst irgendwie so ein bisschen zu
schützen es ist nicht so dass ich von
panzern mit tennis drinnen irgendwie
überrollt werde auf der straße zeit nur
oft so dass zuschauer einen verfolgen
und zu viele stores und das ding
ich weiß nicht ob es richtig ist die
video hochzuladen oder nicht aber ich
mir auf dem herzen und ich dachte ich
teil das mit euch